let's talk about your four pillars for a
second when I was reading that
description to me what came immediately
to mind was a young child that kind of
the epitome of mindfulness you know
someone who has wisdom of a sort who has
wonder for sure who's very giving
because we now have a lot of research
that shows that children are naturally
very altruistic it seems like a child is
kind of the the most mindful person you
can have and you even quote the child is
father to the man you quote that poem in
your book so I was wondering if you kind
of if you agree with that if you think
that we should be looking more to kind
of prolong our childhood in a certain
sense I love the idea of prolonging our
childhood while making it conscious you
see that's the difference right it's the
fact that it's like returning to the
Garden of Eden but with consciousness
it's a TS Eliot poem about you know
returning home but seeing it for the
first time one of the things that i
often use as them as a sort of example
of how i want to react to life and that
has to do with children is the way
children get angry upset they cry that's
right temper tantrum and then two
minutes later it's gone and it's like a
different human being and I think if we
can be like that it would be just an
amazing way to experience life instead
of holding onto resentment and anger and
judgments for years and affecting a
whole experience of life do you think we
need to go to kind of to that extreme in
order to be able to appreciate
mindfulness and incorporate it we need
to kind of experience the not
necessarily burnout as severe as you did
but all of the negative things first or
is it possible to just sail on through
oh I I think absolutely we can
incorporate mindfulness from a very
early age and now increasingly we see
people I mean young children being
taught to meditate in order to have it's
like a tool
that they can use at any point in their
lives my two daughters meditate and
there they encourage each other they
text each other when one is about to
meditate to encourage the other to
remember to do her medication so they're
using it as a tool because even the most
blessed life is going to include
problems challenges tragedies often so
if we have a tool that allows us to
return to that central place we all have
every religion mentions it every
philosophy in Archimedes called it give
me a place to stand and I can move the
world so that place on which we can
stand and deal with whatever life brings
us to me is just an incredible adventure
to learn to go back to that place and
return to it again and again until we
can have easier access to it
you